I'm just gonna screw it all up surprise
for you no peeking what are you gonna
get really swollen
[Music]
Ren's been a really good boy this year
and I wanted to reward him with a
Christmas gift we've been getting a lot
of Electric skateboards in the mail from
a lot of different people a lot of
different manufacturers it's a whole new
wave of technology coming into the fold
right now I thought what better thing to
do with them then to put them all
together in one board there's an 8 foot
piece of plywood about an inch thick
out in the loading dock I want to cut
that into a deck and then take four
boards and put one in each corner and
then use four remotes to actually power
this electric longboard currently we
haven't started but just on paper I'm
100% sure this is gonna work
I take that back I'm not 100% sure it's
gonna work I'm about 95 percent sure
it's gonna work I don't know why I'm
looking at my watch in order to
determine the size and shape of this
board I'm pretty much just gonna follow
this design which is a very classic
longboard style a little bit of in
cutting right here with this nice sort
of rounded nose and tail welcome to the
Masson kids you know people say that
math isn't cool it's actually really
cool and people that know math end up
being your boss we're fine and a half
divided by zero five and a half that's
wait did I do that right
you're not actually gonna be able to
steer because no matter how hard you
lean on it one of the boards will always
just be going straight it'll work and
function a lot more like a real board if
we just do two I figured out the
proportions of this board all the
dimensions on this if I multiply them by
two point five six I'll get the exact
same dimensions on my larger board we're
not gonna have the wheels sticking out
on the outside because our boards are
gonna be here but still it's gonna it's
going
what to cut this down son
my favorite part you know it's like you
do all this measurement you do all this
meticulous measuring measuring twice
measuring three times when it comes to
cutting you can only cut once
[Music]
finger finger mark maybe this one dot
okay the problem with everyone being
forced to stay in the studio is that
people need to eat so I think I've got a
solution there's a Chinese place down
the street and it's one of 75,000
locations available nationwide on grub
hubs we're gonna order from there it's
super simple we just go online or use
the app order delivery comes to our door
just like regular if you guys want to
order some grub hub of your own from one
of the many restaurants in your
neighborhood click the link in the
description below and use promo code
santanico to get seven dollars off your
first order of fifteen dollars or more
and then you can stay in your studio and
eat all you want
tell you run out of money you know it's
a good Chinese food when it's an
unlabeled paper bag lunch is served
you go off your hands so don't get sick
I believe there's some dipping sauces
yeah what you dip sure got spicy mayo
and ketchup so what's the most important
aspect eating food at your desk don't
make a mess and find a good 10 minutes
show to watch wait really but look at
this what is this this cannot be good
for you
what you took a dumpling the chicken on
the inside like a complete mic no food
and it's delicious
thanks God that's this video
[Applause]
[Music]
as you can see I've got the belt sander
out honing in on these nice smooth edges
right here I wanted to show you guys
just how powerful this thing is we're
doing this whole experiment right the
sports coming together pretty well well
midway through all of this I was sitting
here thinking you know how am i I don't
need to attach this at all you know why
because this whole motor comes off of
this deck so I'm just gonna take this
motor off and just screw it right onto
the board down and then it'll be a true
a true skateboard I didn't expect the
board to turn out this nice I thought we
were just gonna cut a piece of plywood
and screw some electric long boards on
to it so I don't just want to cap it off
with like a paint job I think I actually
should go over well I think I think I
should I think I should actually make
this into a board and I put it right
here this is pretty cool this is this is
pretty cool that's what I'm saying I
don't I don't want to ruin it by just
you know not not doing it justice
yeah
can't come this way sir in Bella's
costume I'm in charge of the helmet and
I want this helmet to be able to be worn
by everybody this isn't like some
fancy-schmancy Hollywood costume making
where you have an actor and you make
everything specifically for that actor
no this is the way we do that corridor
digital where you just make it so it's
one size fits all Jake will probably be
the guy in the costume for the video but
I really want to wear it for Halloween
next year make sure it fits me see this
is why I keep secrets to myself to be
the size of the bigger head yeah I'm
gonna make it so it fits everybody I
don't see the purple like right like
what is I'm got I don't have a big so
first off let me just tell you this if
there's a bell curve of head sizes I'm
on the upper end ignore my head size
don't put me in there I'm just gonna
screw it all up oh you have forceps or
something for this use friends CalPERS
knee go wait you want it why do you need
the calories you're also you get stabbed
in the eye
these aren't big enough these aren't big
enough
perfectly I mean I don't think this is
measuring as wide as it could be how you
really should be measuring them 23
inches ish all right 21 so it's really
not that much bigger I know I say I'm so
smart it's only like two extra IQ really
I try granddad at least 25 22 22 how
many memories how many maymays are up in
there dang it about as big as me this is
the quarterly court or digital review
we're just masking it under the guise
that we were building helmets but this
is actually it's just secret data we
keep on piling do you like stingers LEDs
trying to get us thrown pollen up in his
face and like turning it allergic
reactions 21:21
Niko's just barely scooting by here's
the moment of truth for Nick 20 to 1
heads looking a little chubby all that
hair okay
just barely 21 is way was to cut off a
quarter Digital minimum dang am 23
we're in the big boy club alright so now
they know is that needs to be about
eight inches wide about nine and a half
now give you space for ears in here and
padding and all that jazz what is the
circumference of your head hey if you
want to find out the rest of our head
circumference is consider subscribing we
should do that we measure when someone
said and that's like a cliffhanger fall
below 21 your your status sorry ladies
in jeopardy
you know pressure giggle are you alright
today marks a very special day we've
completed the fabrication of the board
got it all stained lost and everything
and now it's ready for griptape I've
never put grip tape on a board before
but from what I hear it's basically like
peeling a sticker and putting it on a
deck so far so good on the application
of the grip tape skaters don't don't
crucify me is the first time I've put
the tape on I mean my philosophy is if
it gets on the board even and there's no
bubbles then you've done your job all
right tape is done now it's real time
I'm gonna put the wheels on and then I'm
going to wrap it and then I'm gonna
bring it in the studio and present it to
our baby boy red the next step in this
is to attach the trucks to the deck
we're gonna have to go all the way
through the whole deck this is a
critical step because you don't want to
get it wrong if you get it wrong then
your boy
[Applause]
all right that should do it
that looks like a board to me see if it
works
uh-huh hey red hey man nice hat Thanks
that's out I got it I got a surprise for
you really yeah like is this what you've
been working on for like the last year
I've been working on for the last three
days and that you haven't been able to
see I just want you to know your
Christmas stocking is filled do you know
what it isn't it no no idea your eyes oh
I know that you've just been doing
nothing but like woodworking all I know
is that you've been cutting wood cuz I
could smell it right no peeking I'm not
peeking no peeking
open your eyes what is that a longboard
not only is it a longboard it's the
world's largest longboard and you know
what you get groups take what's yours
dude hey this is the skateboard that we
got last week isn't it this is the one
that you're able to take off and put
biggest electric skateboard like ever
made I'm assuming people a probably made
big skateboards before but have they
ever been electric I don't know
[Laughter]
okay I'm really impressed I wonder if
it's an easier ride like it's probably
got more like suspension and stuff
there's there's no Dobby here guys
Debbie's been banished from this
electric skateboard we approached it
with the mentality that we were just
gonna strap multiple different electric
long boards to a single piece of plywood
and it turned into this things really
went the other way oh my god
[Music]
you know Christmas is a season of giving
it's like surprisingly agile - let's see
it
[Music]
all right